you
when I was young I found an orphaned
wolf cub in the forest dine our farm I
felt if I could instill rules the proper
boundaries I could harness at a lot of
power of that beast
a few months later while hunting they
had a lesson come turned on me
we're fixing the damage the Avengers did
all those years ago Inhumans are sick
that's dangerous it's evil
lucky to be alive come on Kamala let em
help you I'll take my chances
what if the Avengers were set up I think
you should see for yourself
mr. stark help us with this hi I'm sorry
who are you oh come on it's better be
good you tried to drive the Chimera
have you completely lost your senses
where were you while the world went to
hell this is our fault both of ours
you really think the world is better
without us yes it's always been you
who you are what you are
[Music]
I'm super powers
[Music]
a whole lot
what's up marble fans my name's Casey
Lynch and I'm editor director at Crystal
Dynamics Marvel's Avengers war table is
your direct source for all things
Marvel's Avengers we've got a great show
lined up with new trailers new details
on one of our main villains MODOK and
advanced idea mechanics and we'll take a
first look at coop and war zones if
you've ever thought what is this game or
how does it work
then this is the show for you let's get
into it starting with a story trailer in
the aftermath of a day everything
changed youth so-called heroes
transformed San Francisco into an
infectious gas filled quarantine zone
you unleash disease powerful beings that
wreak havoc throughout our nation so I
ask you again dr. banner do the Avengers
pose a danger to society yes I can
promise you this I will use this second
chance to make
aim we'll find a cure for the inhuman
disease as a founding member of tech
giant advanced idea mechanics or aim
George tarlatan drums of a world made
better through science but even as aimed
promises a cure to envy and human
infection and the revolutionary adaptoid
project offers a world protected by
science tarleton a victim of a day
himself uses ames technological might
and the public sphere of in humans to
convince the world that the
super-powered are uncontrollable and
cannot be trusted his deranged obsession
drives him to become MODOK mental
organism designed only for killing when
choosing a villain we knew we needed
someone who had the muscle and mental
capacity to become an Avengers level
threat we also wanted a new face for
modern Avengers fans big face but comic
fans know MODOK is anything but new his
origin in Marvel Lord
dates back more than 50 years to October
of 1967 in tales of suspense now with
aim strive to manipulate public fear and
his ability to control machines with his
mind tarlatan and aim are the most
sophisticated threat the Avengers have
ever faced but a teenage fan girl named
Kamala Khan doesn't trust aim in fact
she's convinced that aim is
experimenting on her fellow and humans
under the guise of finding a cure and
she believes George tarlatan was behind
the plot to discredit the Avengers and
she has proof as you pick up the trail
of the long disbanded Avengers you'll
advance the story of the single-player
campaign unlocking more and more hero
specific missions we know you've been
asking for new gameplay that's not from
a day we hear you so here's a
playthrough a part of a new Thor hero
mission called once an Avenger
[Music]
[Music]
we're here live with the aim experience
in Manhattan witnessing the return of
the Avengers for things they appear to
be attacking the city keep rolling keep
rolling is it any coincidence that this
attack comes on the very day that aim is
supposed to unveil their promising new
adaptoid program
you're welcome
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you should know
wait is that for holy crap Thor - the
hell did you come from I was serving a
common dish when it started raining
bolts of metal from the skies it's
unbelievably good to see you yeah
dramatic don't you think
it doesn't matter he's here now you were
supposed to do
[Music]
[Music]
they're turning into the deck something
calls it cooked up to crap okay
just like old times
and drops in bhau's max Kamal are you
okay
[Music]
don't worry she's up to it
chimeras still losing altitude though
and you hold it up with wind it's fairly
simple part
[Music]
you killed Captain America before your
honor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're the terrorists in the same
experience story not on my watch
the camara can't go down not again
bought it some drugs heading for the
command deck got my hands full kid I'm
on nice security subsystems just came
back online it's working
[Music]
you don't have to
done Avengers come on Tony
we're trying to restart the engines but
there's not enough power
we're out of time people brace for
impact Hey
[Music]
once an Avenger is a great example of a
hero mission a single-player campaign
experience focusing on a specific
playable character hero missions give us
a chance to tell more of each heroes
story and showcase the variety and depth
of our hero designs let's take a quick
look at how Thor plays with the game's
combat systems players can stream
together combos of heavy and wide
attacks or hold for signature attacks
combat versatility is one of Thor
strengths from making use of Mjolnir to
pin enemies from a distance or bringing
the sky down on his foes in addition to
core combat moves the god of thunder has
a wide variety of skills to unlock that
give him access to classic moves this is
one of our favorites manual targeting we
largely draw our influence from writer
Jason Aaron's run on the Mighty Thor
comic manual targeting allows you to
quickly mark your enemies for
bull's-eyes with mule NER and one by one
you can mark them and knock them down as
Milner comes back to you follow that up
with a powerful ground pound and you've
got a mighty combo manual targeting is a
great ranged attack but if
up-close-and-personal is more your style
go with the hammer spin or mule near
cyclone
heroes have three special heroic moves
assault ultimate and support when
designing our heroics we started with
the signature moves from the comics and
movies that we've always wanted to play
the assault corrode charges the fastest
and in some cases you can store multiple
charges to use strategically as a part
of your combos you can perform these
after charging your heroic meters with
normal attacks for instance Natasha's
assault heroic is widow's bite which is
an electroshock projectile move you
might recognize you can see Matt using
it right here Ichiro also has a unique
support heroic that's designed to
enhance co-op in team play for example
for support Warriors fury lets him
channel the power of the gods to
supercharge his open force and grants a
period of invulnerability for nearby
team members you can see this in action
and when Ironman gets the buff as he
flies through Thor's support Ultimates
take longer to charge but they're
definitely worth the waiting they have
more screen clearing power and some even
have residual effects like Thor's
Bifrost ultimate Thor's ultimate heroic
channel's the power of the nine realms
and his Bifrost
taps into Muspelheim to bypass
unbreakable shield allowing Thor to use
the power of the Bifrost bridge to do
maximum damage we know everyone plays
differently so we have melee ranged
aerial and ground combat skills to
tailor your hero to your playstyle as
your heroes are an experience they gain
access to new skills skill points allow
you to unlock new moves combos and even
new versions of attacks as you build up
your heroes you begin to see how
unlocking and mastering the separate
core skills offers a ton of depth and
variety on its own for every hero
and that's before here perks artifacts
and any kind of later game progression
so why is all of this important because
it means your thor will play differently
than my Thor and my Hulk will play
different than yours another way to
customize your heroes is with gear we've
previously talked about the different
rarities and how perks will give you
powerful modifiers for even more
customization some perks apply special
damage like plasma or gamma or cos
status effects like shrink which will
shrink enemies and reduce damage to
defense you can see Iron Man using gamma
gear in this shop and eagle-eyed fans
probably noticed his laser sweep was
green instead of red no that wasn't a
bug when you have gamma gear equipped it
grants a bonus damage modifier and
changes the emissive color of your
attack and voila green lasers we know
that if you look good you'll play good
the crystal team has really enjoyed
creating all new outfits for these
heroes and drawing from Marvel's 80-year
history to bring so many classic outfits
to the game each hero has dozens of
outfits drawn from some of the most
recognizable eras and story arcs you can
earn them over the course of the story
campaign by completing missions and
deciphering patterns
there's Iron Man suit from the 2014
original sins storyline or Donald Blake
which is a nod to an alias of Thor's who
first appeared in 1962 s journey into
mystery issue 83 or Tony's stark tech
outfit that was inspired by the bleeding
edge armor that first appeared in ad
vincible Iron Man number 25 in 2010
while there are a ton of outfits you
learn just by playing some will require
completing iconic mission chains to earn
each heroes iconic outfit and some
outfits will only be available in our
online marketplace you could even
customize your attitude and let out your
inner Hulk with the right emote
I don't think that's canon those are
just some of the ways you'll be able to
build and spec out your heroes ok I
think it's time for another trailer this
gives us a first look at how all that
customization is especially fun when you
play together
this is co-op and war zones these
attacks they harvest their powers to the
temperature of these Inhumans
georgie-boy is gearing up for war
programmable power under our control
no heroes entire worlds of terrible
danger
time is here I could pull some strings
to spruce up the armory get ourselves
some new toys to play with dangerous
ones a derivative of D Richard
[Music]
you got to get this bird in the air
before Ian comes looking for us
Jarvis is unencrypted the schematics and
we'll get our tech heads on new gear
ASAP
[Music]
[Music]
illness which nation state is ain't
blamin hooded war with
heroes are people and people can be
corrupted don't stop them it's just one
more thing to regret on my deathbed
[Music]
you want to see powers there we go
time for doing
[Music]
so far we talked about the story hero
missions and customization now let's
talk about war zones war zones are
missions which you can play with up to a
total of four players or solo with an AI
companion team made up of your unlocked
and leveled heroes whether playing hero
missions or war zones
you always make forward progress with
your heroes on your Helicarrier you'll
use the war table to launched missions
with a variety of objectives and
challenges as you saw on the coop
trailer each mission is grounded in
story so whether you're in the campaign
or war zones you're always working
together to stop aim and rebuild the
resistance you get missions from Jarvis
Maria Hill Hank Pym and more characters
from Marvel history once you pick your
mission you'll board the Quinn jet where
you can match make switch heroes choose
your loadout and of course pick the
right look and attitude for the job as
you start playing missions across the
globe you'll realize aim is entrenched
themselves in cities and remote
locations alike all in the name of
research war zones range from wide-open
spaces designed for exploration and team
traversal to dense interiors with a
variety of objective based challenges
boss fights and rewards
here's a mission we saw on the coop
trailer called
to tame a Titan where we can see some
team play there's this cool shot of Iron
Man but you may have missed Kamala and
Hulk performing a team finisher on that
poor guy back there when you max out
some larger enemies stun meter two
heroes can come together to perform a
team finisher which gives you a chance
to take them down much faster see what
makes the dream work
living the hero life is all about growth
getting stronger and better equipped to
play smarter and there are plenty of
upgrades to help you do just that as you
progress through the campaign you'll
also be rebuilding and upgrading the
chimera your Helicarrier which is your
own flying base the resistance is a
group who have banded together in the
five years since a day some are inhuman
and have powers some are former shield
agents who refused to pledge allegiance
to aim and some just want to help you'll
join their cause in the field by working
directly with factions like the inhuman
alliance and shield agents dum-dum Dugan
Nick Fury and war earning faction
reputation will give you access to new
challenges
new vendors and more powerful items
there will always be new threats on the
horizon so you want to ensure your
Avengers are ready for anything we've
talked about a lot today but that's kind
of the point this is a really big
ambitious game Marvel's Avengers isn't
just a global high stakes race to
rebuild the Avengers to save the
Inhumans and uncover the truth about
aims plans that's just the beginning
this is a brand-new original Avengers
single-player story that you can enjoy
on your own made the Crystal Dynamics
way but it's also an experience you can
play with your friends that will grow as
we add new heroes new regions and new
story all at no additional cost thank
you for following us and believing in us
I want to give a big shout out to our
community thank you for caring and
telling us what you think we're
listening and as fans ourselves we're
all working every day to make marvel's
avengers worthy of your support please
stick around after the show to ask
questions and chat on behalf of the
whole Marvel's Avengers team thank you
for tuning in to the first marvel's
avengers war table in the coming months
we'll talk about our first post-launch
hero our upcoming beta and of course our
launch when marvel's avengers arrives
September 4th
I'm Casey Lynch and I'll see you next
time